microsoft have said you'll need a 4k TV  if you want to appreciate the full  benefits of the upcoming Xbox Scorpio  which is said to be significantly more  powerful than the xbox one Xbox head  Phil Spencer told Eurogamer if you own a  1080p TV then you should buy an xbox one  s because Scorpio is not going to do  anything for you Scorpio is designed as  a 4k console and if you don't have a 4k  TV the benefit we've designed for you're  not going to see while Spencer didn't  discuss pricing plans for the Scorpio he  added that it will be a premium price  above the xbox one s which starts at  three hundred bucks and supports HDR and  4k video project Scorpio is set to  launch in the holiday season of next  year let me know what you think of it in  that commenting box down below and stay  tuned to GameSpot's for all the e3  latest  you